et maintenant on va montrer les la mode
anglaise alors claude sabbah et si les
grands bals j'espère que vous allez
m'aider parce que moi avant john
galliano je le connais pas ce que je
vois en couverture de bleach les autres
je les vois des fois avant le faith mais
à part ça c'est tout ce que je sais
alors qu'est ce qui se passe en
angleterre allemand novitec beaucoup de
choses et on va parler john galliano
premier puisque cette année il est le
designer de la nuit il a deux oscars et
c'est quelqu'un de très jeunes deux
awards
ok merci mais bon et donc non c'est
quelqu'un de très jeunes qui a fait
saint martin saint martin qui est la
plus grande école et il est sorti en 84
et il a tout du tout beaucoup de gens
qui ont cru en lui et donc ça va très
bien donc j'avais vu un de ses premiers
défilés qui s'appelait l'innocence ou
minet forgotten innocent
et c'était très très beau donc j'étais
toujours revoir ses défilés
et ce dernier défilé est très jolie on
va voir une robe
d'ailleurs la dernière collection très
engagé de les français vont chercher les
idées en angleterre mais lassé des
anglais sont distribués en france vendus
en france à ce qu'il y ait autant dans
glee qui viennent à paris
oui parce que les gens mis du temps à
avoir envie d'aller à londres tout ça
mais c'est vraiment une ville qui
finalement être très spécial très seul
succès une île
ouais donc déjà il ya beaucoup d'eau au
tour donc les gens pensent pas la même
chose
on peut le dire partout diaconu d'aller
piller ce qui vient de se faire
distribuer en france
ils vendent un petit peu copié à lui si
je pense pas qu'il sera au pied parce
que paris tienne vraiment sur sa propre
image et ça je pense vraiment que c'est
un peu un mythe l'idée de copier parce
qu'on comptait reparler très à la mode
n'ont vu que la haute couture et le côté
culture marche vraiment très très fort
donc je pense que paris est aussi très à
la mode mais eux sont complètement
différents et sur notre manière de voir
les choses donc john au dj star
on me dit que c'était très très dur pour
lui au début ils avaient toutes ces
dépenses à faire lui-même qui ça il a
quitté l'école mais déjà ses robes et
lui c'est qui alors lui c'est patrick
cox que ces déchets sur effet des
chaussures très drôle alors on peut les
regarder ma chère si elles sont même
allés nunca une fleur de lys au front
chaud ça marque
il a déjà travaillé avec kevin west
faune dans l'école de l'union westwood
john galliano aussi viviane westwood
s'est on peut dire que c'est un
personnage assez exceptionnel et musées
qui tenir
et lui c'est nos cieux david fils donne
alors un monsieur d'abord qui faisait de
la danse qui avait sa compagnie qui
était chorégraphe qui a beaucoup joué en
france qui avait joué à avignon
wen ok il a commencé d'abord à faire des
vêtements pour le théâtre nancy il a
décidé de danser lui même et puis après
il personne puisque né qui tient le
micro cravate à la main mais c'est très
chic c'est précieux d'accord et voilà
donc lui a décidé aussi de collections
lui c'est un personnage complètement
différent il a une collection beaucoup
plus couture vous allez voir un exemple
d'une de ses robes l'a fait mal et c'est
magnifique et ça qu'ils ont préféré
surtout on adore tous ces
personne ne dira alors que les choses
allaient bien
[Musique]
systar lui les matinées qu'alors lui
tandis que le dinosaure avaient rapporté
ces choses-là chaîne et à l'embauché le
voilà et le prochain oui parce que
maintenant on va voir le sujet qui a été
réalisé par laurence touitou à londres
depuis trois jours si j'ai différents
modes et puis des gens
la revue est aussi de styliste richie
ron et ding rights ont présenté une
collection qui n'avaient rien à voir qui
était complètement hors contexte et qui
en plus je pense ne seront pas tellement
sellerie les détails les détails ça se
voit mais c'est pas grave c'est l'heure
du britanno les corrections de ne rien
rater de finale andy tu es abonné vous
mettez un pouce bleus